great well uh it's a pleasure to be here
and talk to you today about
hemato oncology applications of immune
repertoire sequencing
and before i get into the content of my
talk
uh i'd like to mention that immune
repertoire sequencing data is
is a tremendously versatile data type
and it can be applied to immuno-oncology
research
immunology and infectious disease
research
and as i will describe today hematology
research
where it can be used to detect and track
b-cell and t-cell clones of interest so
for a bit more granularity on it on the
presentation
i'm going to start with a background on
immune repertoire sequencing
before proceeding to describe
some of the reasons why the field has
migrated towards
immune repertoire sequencing as a tool
for hematology research
and then after that i'll discuss spectra
typing analysis
as a tool to interpret repertoire data
before finally
finishing the presentation with a
discussion of somatic hypermutation
and its impact on clonality and clone
tracking applications
so when we talk about hematology
disorders uh those can be either of
myeloid or lymphoid lineage cells uh
within the linea at the lymphoid lineage
cells a subset
are relevant to the immune repertoire
analysis
and those are the t lymphocytes and b
lymphocytes
b lymphocytes give rise to malignancies
more often than t lymphocytes and
those are the primary focus of this
presentation now depending on the
developmental stage of the b
cell one can observe a number of
different cancer types
some of which are shown on the right
side of this slide
b cells are typified by the the b cell
receptor this is an incredibly diverse
structure that is on the surface of b
cells and can recognize antigen
b cells play an important role in
neutralizing
foreign invaders the the b-cell receptor
consists of a heavy chain and a light
chain
the heavy chain which will be the focus
of this presentation
consists of a variable domain which is
responsible for
antigen recognition but also a constant
region which determines the effector
function
of the b-cell receptor now a b-cell
receptor is membrane-bound
but the secreted form of the b-cell
receptor is called an
antibody and
one of the reasons why there's such
incredible
b-cell receptor diversity is through the
a genetic mechanism
called ddj recombination and
within this process b cells actually
alter their genome
to create millions upon millions of
different receptors
vdj recombination uh refers to the the
combination of tanningly arranged
variable
diversity and joining genes this process
imparts
combinatorial diversity within the igh
receptor
but additional diversity comes from
exonucleotide chewbact
at the ends of the the v gene and j
genes but also the addition of random
bases called
n additions to the enzyme tdt
now apart from vdj recombination the
sequences of the igh
can undergo further diversification to
somatic hypermutation
which introduces point mutations to the
to the to the igh chain
but also isotype switching which can
swap out the constant portion
of of the receptor to uh one of nine
isotypes
and if you note the upper left-hand
portion of this slide
a diagram of the rearranged ig's chain
you'll note there are
fr or framework and cdr regions
of the rearranged igh chain the cdr
regions form
loops that directly interact with
antigen and play
a primary role in determining the
antigen specificity of the receptor
while the framework regions provide
structural support
and it's been recognized by the field
for quite so
some time that this igh rearrangement
uh is really an ideal target for
tracking
uh b cells of interest and
uh in this slide i i've highlighted some
of the key developments
in the analysis of igh rearrangements
in the early days the fields utilized
southern blot
hybridization as a method for detection
of b and t cell
malignancies that all changed with the
advent
of pcr uh one
uh observed singleplex pcr where
individual variable genes were amplified
and then and then analyzed
but a big breakthrough came in 2003.
with the development of the biomed 2
multiplex pcr primer set
and and this made the the process of
pcr-based analysis of the immune reptile
much easier and you'll note that
actually relatively recently has the
field been applying
uh next generation sequencing to analyze
uh
receptor rearrangements so this was was
done initially with five prime race
and and bioman two primers and and here
it was demonstrated that this approach
could achieve
a limit of detection less than one in
ten thousand cells
now the the last point on this timeline
uh 2017
we introduced primer sets using ampliseq
based
technology for immune repertoire
analysis
and the the key feature of this approach
is that one can use many many primers
in a single reaction so there's there's
not the issue of primary primary
interactions that has
historically made immune repertoire
sequencing uh
quite challenging and so we are able to
design primer sets that can amplify all
of the known
variable genes and alleles and thus
provide comprehensive
coverage of the immune reptile
so with that i'd like to introduce the
oncoming immune repertoire portfolio
we've developed assays for interrogating
human t
cell and b cell repertoires but also
tools to interrogate the mouse t and b
cell repertoire
i won't be talking about those in this
presentation uh so
we focus uh within the b cell receptor
on the heavy chain because
this is the most diverse and sequence
content and with the t
cell receptor that the beta chain for
the same reason
and within the human assays you'll note
that we have two
types of acid the lr or long lead and sr
or short read lr refers to a long
amplicon approach
that provides a sequence of all three
cdr domains
and this requires non-ffpe rna input
the complement to this are the sr assays
and this targets the cbr3 region of the
igh chain or the tcr beta
and is compatible with both fresh and
ffpe preserved material both dna
and rna so
uh with with that i'd like to uh
apologize uh
bring bring us to the the second part of
this presentation which is to understand
why the field has been
migrating towards immune repertoire
sequencing for hemato oncology research
so i'll start by describing clonality
testing
and the related minimal residual disease
research testing
before finally proceeding to somatic
hypermutation analysis
so uh clonality testing uh refers to
uh a single sample analysis where one
wishes to
search for the presence of a dominating
rearrangement
that dominating rearrangement is
assumed to belong to a malignancy and
once identified it can be used to track
a clone
over time so the this initial clonality
testing through a diagnostic sample or
pre-treatment sample is an essential
part of the subsequent minimal residual
disease analysis
by immune repertoire sequencing and this
distinguishes
immune repertoire sequencing based
minimal residual disease detection
from traditional approaches like flow
cytometry
so the the reason why the field has been
migrating to
uh immune repertoire sequencing is that
it allows one to achieve a very low
limit of detection
uh 10 to the negative six has been uh
demonstrated regularly
uh and uh this distinguishes it from
from other
uh common approaches
so within the uh the larger umbrella of
rare phone detection
we have created the igh sr
assay for for rare clone detection and
tracking
and you'll note uh from the cartoon on
the left side of the slide
this consists of amplicip primers that
target the framework 3 region
of the igh chain and the joining gene
region so this provides an amplicon that
spans that key
cdr3 region which is used to track b
cells over time the the accompanying
software that that
with this assay allows one to identify
clones
but also clonal lineages and these refer
to sets of uh
rearrangements that are believed to be
related by descent
but differ owing to somatic
hypermutation and class switch
recombination
and through uh through a number of
studies we and others have demonstrated
that this assay
is able to detect clones at 10 to the
negative 6 limit of detection
so here i have an example of one such
study
here we we took genomic dna from a b
cell line ca46 and spiked it
in to peripheral blood leukocyte genomic
dna
at a frequency of 10 to the negative six
so two picograms of cell line dna
per two micrograms of genomic dna
and from this large stock of material
then we prepared
30 libraries of two micrograms each and
sequenced each
using the ighsr assay now
two picograms of genomic dna is
approximately one-thirds
cell equivalent and so in an optimal
situation you might
expect to detect the rear the
rearrangement at a frequency
uh or of of one in every three libraries
and in fact we we detected in 10 out of
the 30 libraries
very close to expectation and from this
data you can
back calculate the number of libraries
needed to obtain
a 95 or 99 uh
probability of detection at 10 to
negative 6 and this fits very closely
what
with what others have observed in the
fields so this really highlights
the reason why the field has been
gravitating towards
immune repertoire sequencing for the
rare phone detection application
now the the other application i'd like
to discuss is
a somatic hyper mutation analysis within
the context of chronic lymphocytic
leukemia
and it's been established that the level
of somatic hypermutation of the variable
gene
is an as that can help
predict the outcome of that cancer type
cll having a vg mutation of greater than
two percent
uh sometimes referred to as mcl tends to
have a better prognosis than than cll
that
has an unmutated variable gene or less
than two percent somatic hypermutation
with that said this is an imperfect
prognostic biomarker
and there's a thought that potentially
adding in
isotype information of the b cell could
further improve this stratification
potential
and that follows from the observation
that isotype switching
involves the creation and repair of dna
double strand breaks
and thus could serve as a window into
the proficiency of the b
cell to uh to to repair uh
damage so with this in mind we created
the igh
lr assay for somatic hypermutation
analysis you'll note that
again ample seek primers targeting the
framework 1 region of the igh
and the constant gene region so this
provides a readout of the cdr1
2 and 3 regions of the of the receptor
but also the isotype
and this can actually distinguish all
nine isotypes from one another
so one uh can evaluate the somatic
hypermutation
through the variable gene portion of the
amplicon measure clonality and track
clones through the tdr3
but then i have that extra piece of
isotype information and i'll describe
how that that's
can be useful and as part of
the development of this assay we have
compared the data from the somatic
hypermutation data from the dashi with
orthologist approaches such as sanger
sequencing
or ngs and there's a a very strong
correlation as
as one might expect now
uh when uh
when i proceed into the next portion of
this uh presentation i want to introduce
the concept of spectra typing and how
this may
help interpret the the
repertoire data produced by the ighsr or
ighlr assays
and the term spectrotyping has been
around for for quite
some time one of the first instances in
the literature that that you may find
comes from a paper by gorsky in 1994
and this described a method for
analyzing the t
cell repertoire and this involves a
singleplex
amplification of individual variable
genes using
fr3 and constant gene prime repairs
each pcr product was loaded into a
separate well of a gel
and then visualized and in healthy
individuals
one would observe for each variable gene
a roughly gaussian distribution of band
intensity
where each band corresponds to a
different cbr through the nucleotide
length
now in an individual with an abnormality
either autoimmune disease or otherwise
the
the the plots would deviate from this
gaussian distribution
and on panel b of this of this slide i
have an example of uh
myasthenia gravis this is a t cell
mediated autoimmune disorder
where you're observing a non-gaussian
distribution
now i set this as context because with
ngs data we can take this type of
analysis to uh
to a higher level and here i'd like to
introduce the
the spectra typing plots within the ion
reporter companion analysis
for these assays so here you're looking
at a spectrotyping analysis
from the ighlr assay
and in this plot the rearrangements
detected in a sample are displayed from
left to right across the plot by the
variable gene identity
and along the y-axis by the cdr3
nucleotide length
the size of the circle indicates the
frequency of a particular v-gene
cdr3 nucleotide length combination and
the coloring indicates the level of
somatic hypermutation
so you can note there's a lot of
information in a single plot
and with within ion reporter these plots
are interactive
so i can scroll my cursor over that plot
and bring up extra information
at any position so for example
at the at the noted location i've now
brought up a pop-up window
which indicates the v gene is v323
the cdr3 nucleotide length is 48 base
pairs
the largest clone at this position has a
frequency of about 1
and with a vg mutation of 13.7
so what i'm showing you here is a
healthy individual
a polyclonal repertoire and you can note
there are many circles in this plot that
are about the same size
but now let's take a look at an
individual with cll
so here it's quite obvious the
difference between the
the previous sample uh one can observe a
dominating clone
uh that dwarfs the size of the other
clones uh
the other parts of the of this plot and
you can note by the coloring
that this this clone likely has a level
of somatic hypermutation
greater than zero and by hovering over
it we can bring up additional
information
and here you'll note that
at this position in the repertoire the
largest clone has a frequency of 44
and a v gene percentage mutation of 8.3
percent
noted at the bottom of the pop-up so
within cll
this 8.3 beaching mutation would be
interpreted as a good sign
and so a potentially better prognosis
now you'll note at the top there are
buttons that may be
clicked by by the user in fact
with these plots we can highlight a
partition the repertoire by isotype
such that we're only viewing
rearrangements having a particular item
type so now
instead of viewing the entire repertoire
i'm going to click on igm
and in doing so uh i again see this
dominating uh
a circle corresponding to the the
malignant clone
which suggests that the clone express is
igm
now i'm going to click on igd
and here you see it again so this this
cll clone
must express igm and ige potentially as
the product of
uh alternative splicing now the
the same in the information that we just
observed through spec
the spectrotyping analysis is also found
within the clone submarine tables of ion
reporter
these are searchable sortable tables
and each row of this table shows the
features of
a different clone so you'll note that
the first two rows of this table
corresponds to the two clones that we
just observed
one expressing igm and one expressing
igd
and these have the same level of
mutation of 8.3
and to the leftmost portion of this
table you can note a column that
indicates
the lineage id the software will
automatically assign clones to clonal
lineages
uh based on on the features of that
rearrangement
so you can see that the first two clones
are believed to be related by descent
and if we take a look at the lineage
summary table again within ion reporter
this provides a breakdown
of the features of each clonal lineage
and so the lineage id number one the
most
abundant clonal lineage consists of two
clones expressing
igm and igd and having a combined
frequency of
nearly 80 percent of the repertoire so
clearly this is an abnormal sample
uh consistent with with cll
that was an easy case now let's take a
look at a more challenging case
this was described uh to me as
a case that was challenging to interpret
through sanger sequencing
owing to polyclonal backgrounds and you
can
you can observe why there's uh there's
really not a dominating clone
in the way that we saw with that
previous sample but here is where the
isotype information
can be useful and and this brings us to
the important part of the second
learning objective
with the isotype information we can
partition the repertoire
and that can help us hone in on an
abnormally
expanded clone so at the top i'm going
to click on igd
and when i do you can note there's a
dominating clone
while the other igd expressing b-cells
are quite rare
so this is abnormal and it suggests that
in fact the clone of
that's that's highlighted in this plot
uh corresponds to the cll and
and thus one can more easily uh
interpret uh the somatic mutation value
of that clone
and just by contrast here i'm going to
click on ig a1 and look at look at those
cells
and they are indeed polyclonal so you
can tell from this
analysis that the malignant clone is not
does not express iga1 that looks
uh looks normal
so now i'm going to switch into the the
third
part of this talk where i want to
describe the impact of somatic
hypermutation on clonality and clone
tracking
applications and to highlight the
importance of
of this phenomenon we're going to look
at a follicular lymphoma research sample
so to to get back to what we discussed
the beginning of this presentation these
cells
unlike t cells have additional
diversification
mechanisms after vdj recombination where
they can undergo somatic hypermutation
and class switch recombination the
somatic hypermutation
introduces essentially point mutations
within the vdj region
which can give rise to any number of
subclones
now in cases where a b cell malignancy
of interest
is undergoing constant somatic
hypermutation
one could have a situation where there
are many subclones
uh that that one may wish to detect and
and
and track by by sequencing
so here's an example of a case
a sample of suspected follicular
lymphoma
and this again was a sample that was
difficult to evaluate for clonality
because as you can note there's not
a clearly dominating clone and this
data was produced by the igh sr assay
from ffpe dna
but with follicular lymphoma it's it's
possible that
the malignant clone could undergo
on could demonstrate ongoing somatic
hypermutation which could give rise to
many subclones
in that case we may observe an excess of
clones
having a particular variable gene cdr3
nucleotide length combination
and i can actually change the coloring
of this plot to highlight
the number of clones within the
repertoire by clicking this button
and if this is the case we may see an
excess of clones then
in one part of the repertoire and
doing so uh you know
with this type of analysis you can you
can really ask
whether this sample it truly is clonal
or whether it's something more benign
like molecular hyperplasia
so uh by clicking that button you can
note that
there is something unusual here one part
of the repertoire has an excess of
clones as we suspected
and this may be consistent with
follicular lymphoma and the information
displayed on this plot is also shown
within
the lineage summary table and you can
take a look at
the first row of this table lineage id
number one
there are actually 38 clones within this
clonal lineage
while the others have one or two so this
is really an
excess number of clones consistent with
ongoing somatic hypermutation creating
this
rich subclonal structure and
without a clonal lineage analysis this
type of feature would be missed because
each of these sub phones individually is
at low frequency
but together they create the signal that
that is that that helps one understand
uh the nature of the sample so from this
i i want to convey that clonal lineage
analysis
uh is an essential part of interpreting
the b-cell repertoire
so with that i i'm going to finish the
talk
to summarize i described b-cell
repertoire sequencing
and and how it has emerged as an
attractive tool for hemato oncology
research
this is owing to the great limit of
detection
the ability to track clones but also
subclones
and then i also noted how it differs
from traditional approaches like
cytometry in that it requires a
pre-treatment or diagnostic sample
i i i discussed spectra typing as a tool
to
interpret the repertoire and further
discuss
how isotype inflammation can help
dissemble ua certain cll cases
where one wishes to analyze the somatic
type mutation
and then i i ended with a a a case
study highlighting the need to identify
clonal lineages
within the b-cell repertoire data and
how that can really help facilitate the
interpretation of the repertoire so with
that i'd like to
thank you for your time and uh really
happy to
take any further questions that you
might have
thank you